وبينما اعلنت الخارجيه الامريكيه عن
استدعاء السفير الروسي لدى واشنطنوف
لتسليمه رساله احتجاج على الحادثه قال
انتونوف ان بلاده لا تريد مواجهه مع
الولايات المتحده وتفضل عدم خلق وضع يمكن
ان تحدث فيه اشتباكات او حوادث غير مقصوده
بين البلدين
وتساءل السفير الروسي كيف سيكون موقف
الولايات المتحده لو اقتربت مسيره روسيه
من نيويورك او
لا نريد اي مواجهه مع الولايات المتحده بل
نرغب في علاقات برغماتيه من اجل شعبي
البلدين وبالاشاره الى تلك المسيره فانها
قادره على حمل 1700 كيلو جرام من متفجرات
وعده قنابل ايضا وانني اتساءل ماذا كانت
الولايات المتحده لتفعل لو انها رصدت
طائره بلا طيار روسيه قرب سواحل سان
فرانسيسكو او نيويورك مثلا
وقال السفير الروسيه
ابلغت عن المنطقه التي حدث فيها التصادم
بانها منطقه عمليات عسكريه خاصه وحذرت من
دخولها كما كشف انه تبادل وجهه النظر مع
مساعده وزير الخارجيه الامريكي كارن دون
فريند التي نقلت مخاوف بلادها
مصطلح المياه الدوليه تشوبه بعض
الاشكاليات فشبه جزيره القرم مثلا جزء من
الفيدراليه الروسيه والولايات المتحده لا
تعترف بهذا الوضع ولكن ما الداعي الى
استفزاز سلاحي البحريه والجو في روسيا
علينا ان نزن افعالنا بميزان دقيق وان لا
ننسى ما يحدث في شرق اوروبا ومثل ما ترون
فاننا امير الى خلق وضعيات نستطيع فيها
مواجهه اصطدام غير مقصود او حوادث غير
متعمده بين الفيدراليه الروسيه والولايات
المتحده
وفي بيان اصدره لاحقا قال السفير الروسي
لدى واشنطن على
المسيرات الامريكيه تجمع بيانات
الاستخباراتيه تستخدمها كييف لضرب القوات
والاراضي الروسيه واضاف السفير الروسي ان
على الولايات المتحده ان تكف عن الطيران
بالقرب من الحدود الروسيه حسب قوله وعبر
اناتولي انتونوف عن اعتقاده باهميه
الابقاء على خطوط الاتصال مفتوحه مع
واشنطن
وفي تعقيب على حادثه تحطم المسيره
الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود نقلت وكاله
رويترز عن وزير الدفاع البريطاني بنورس ان
على روسيا احترام المجال الجوي الدولي من
جانبها نقلت بوليتيكو عن دبلوماسيين رفيع
في اوروبا الشرقيه قوله ان حادثه اسقاط
المسيره الامريكيه مؤشر على عدوانيه
السلوك الروسي كما تظهر اهميه البحر
الاسود والحاجه الى وجود نهج بشانه على
المدى المتوسط والطويل
معنى الان من موسكو مراسله الجزيره رانيا
الدريدي لنتوقف معها على ردود الفعل واخر
التفاعلات الروسيه المتعلقه بهذا التطور
اللافت المتعلق بالمسيره الامريكيه
نعم ازدهار من الواضح ان هناك استياء كبير
في الاوساط السياسيه الروسيه روسيا تنظر
الى هذا الحادث على انه استفزاز من قبل
الولايات المتحده وتعتبر انه امر غير
مقبول به وفقا لتصريحات السفير الروسي لدى
الولايات المتحده فقد اشار الى ان
الطيران الحربي الطياري الطيارين الروس
كانوا قد تصرفوا باحترافيه كبيره للغايه
ولم يستخدموا اي اسلحه تجاه المسيره
الامريكيه فضلا عن ذلك هنا ود الاشاره الى
ان وزاره الدفاع الروسيه كانت قد اشارت
الى ان المنطقه التي تم فيها سقوط الطائره
او المسيره الامريكيه هي تقع في ما يسمى
نظام الاستخدام المؤقت الذي تم الاعلان
عنه بسبب العمليه العسكريه التي تديرها
روسيا على الاراضي الاوكرانيه تم ابلاغ
جميع الدول المعنيه بهذا النظام ومع ذلك
[تصفيق]
الامريكيه فضلا عن ذلك تساءل السفير
الامريكي ماذا كانت ستفعل الولايات
المتحده ان كانت هناك مسيره روسيه تحلق
على مقربه من نيويورك او سان فان
فرانسيسكو واشار لان الرد الامريكي حينها
لكان حازما ولا ما سمحت الولايات المتحده
بانتهاك الجوي اذا روسيا بحسب تعبيره لا
تريد التصعيد ولكن هذا الامر غير مقبول
تاثيرات تستخدم او تجمع المعلومات
الاستخباريه الاستخباراتيه لصالح
السلطات الاوكرانيه لتستخدم فيما بعد لضرب
الاراضي والقوات الروسيه الجزيره رانيا
دريدي شكرا جزيلا لك